michael fassbender james mcavoy from
next summer's x-men apocalypse I'd like
to bring out the rest of the cast
joining us tonight
please welcome Evan Peters Nicholas
Hoult
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yes yes for rain yeah that's great
guess who arranged the seeding great
move a lot yes they do
oh my let's talk Olivia since you were
playing this has been a dream of yours
to play a superhero is that right it has
been your entire life you have wanted to
play a superhero
yeah yeah I think a lot of people do
yeah
alright now you're playing psylocke yes
and what do you got the word when you
got the word that this was happening
that you were gonna play this character
what once we had uh I was I was really
excited because silac actually is has
been one of my favorite excellent
characters mostly because she's you know
so morally ambiguous she's she's a bad
guy with a good heart and the thing that
I actually always loved about
psylocke is that you know cheese um what
happened what's so funny I laugh with
you he's telepathic and telekinetic and
and so you know superhero is a lot of
times you know they don't want to kill
but they will kill but Psylocke she can
create anything with her mind and she
could kill from afar like magneto or
storm but she chooses to create a sword
and kill up close she likes to kill up
close she likes to kill up close and
kill and as brutal way as possible and
that to me was just the coolest thing
about character
that makes that makes you a sociopath
yeah how close you're going to be to the
actual cartoon because people wondering
what you're going to look like and
people know what the cartoon psylocke
looks like I think we have that here and
we don't know how close you're going to
be is it gonna be the same but it'll be
the same costume except for this part I
come in I come into the deficit with
that part but the costume is exactly
like that just a lot less here and here
right I'm sorry there's a lot of there's
a lot of lubrication involved in getting
you into the car it's true James and
thank you for knowing that but someone
needs to help get lucky why yeah yeah
they Lube me if he's the truth they lose
me down and I step into this latex we
did a whole latex fitting yes
[Laughter]
all right okay Andy you weren't paying
attention earlier I just blacked out
they lubricate the costume and then you
step in costume and they lubricate knees
there's to use like butter margarine
margarine
what do you tie though when were you
born it was right you know well you know
when you're in a pinch you use what you
got yeah they based me first and then
they see me and then two women Lube me
up and then um then we I'm sorry I'm
sorry
yeah two women yeah Lube all right we
got it yeah the first day I put on the
latex suit I was out there I was really
excited to be with these guys and I've
met Michael and James and everybody and
I was just so excited and and then I I
went to like started like okay I want to
do a really good job and I just popped
the crotch of the latex is broke
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I guess bribes popping crotch popping
can be a superpower yeah beware Kabang
oh I have to ask Oscar question Oscar
playing apocalypse okay
[Applause]
the oldest and most powerful of the
mutants and so I'm questioning and we
actually you look at that you look at
the photograph or the drawing of the
character that's not what we're quite
that's not quite area look at that
second we'll clean that up we're on the
road folks no one knows what they're
doing and they all went out drinking
last night a lot of bars in San Diego
here how did you come up with a voice
that would match how intimidating his
character has to be he has to be the
most powerful character in the universe
yeah well we're the thing is I mean it's
still an ongoing thing because the suit
that I wear is incredibly noisy so I
have to ADR a hundred percent of my
dialogue so right now it actually does
it matter what I sound like so it could
be falsetto like meaning you're gonna
add all of the voice later on yeah cuz
what does your suit do it squeaks or
something yeah because it's a huge giant
sneaker it's like yeah I would love it
if they released a version of the movie
with with that yeah say wouldn't it be
great if we never feel like here he
comes
[Music]
hi everybody every time he says
something evil everyone's like oh she
used all the Lube yeah you can use the
butter gotta keep drifting back to that
subject
Evon kitchen scene in x-men days of
people I have to say that is one of my
favorite action scenes of all time
because I had never seen anything quite
like it and it's also it's poetic and
it's funny it's all at the same time I
thought that was absolutely offense but
must have been one of your favorite
scenes to shoot yeah absolutely
I mean your character just gets to run
around and you're doing all these really
hilarious things was it hard cuz you're
running around the walls at like the
speed of light you're doing all these
funny pranks on everyone during a
gunfight how did you even shoot that was
it at all physical yeah and it was yeah
very physical well we're out of time I
literally I didn't really do much I have
to give credit to the special effects
team me and all those stunt guys because
I didn't do jack [ __ ]
[Laughter]
honest that's why you'll never go far in
this business ask the same question I
would say I did it all I did it myself
you would be like a jackass all right
we have you guys you clown around a lot
on the set there's BB gun fights there's
yes BB gun fight yeah not so much in
this this one target practice in this
one but yeah no so much fat unifight
there the deluge ocean
wait you shot who did you shoot in the
absolute hell no new plays bill Stryker
those are dangerous I mean BB guns
there's an element of danger they're
protective eyewear
yeah but he's shot him in the ass he
does good plays there's lots of flesh
yeah so you've literally are they're
trying to shoot a movie this is a
big-budget movie and there's a lot of
running around and you guys they're
trying to get you on the set and you
have BB guns and you're firing at each
other yeah
the last one was worse they actually
stopped us in the end because people had
like lumps bleeding out shooting what
are the caution ladies KATU complained
that the caution Department felt unsafe
at work so we had to down our weapon
it's perfectly cool but it might be
because who was were you locked in your
trailer not coming out because Nicholas
is on top of it was like he was coming
in the skylight he shot me through the
crack of the door was brilliant shot a
kitty right the window your your actors
who are insured you can't get hurt and
that's why we're insured you're trying
you're saying if we look very closely at
the movie we'll see lots of just hits
and wealth in your day in Larry day we
listen carefully you'll be squeaking
right we started off we then started the
punching game and then from the punching
game we've got youth but and oh yeah I'm
necessarily hard do you Magnus I will
tell you with someone who's who's right
here that was hard
i honest and but it's gone from that to
like a weird slapping game as well
what's the slapping game games just
[Laughter]
[Applause]
laughing game involves alcohol but of
course yeah and this it's not really a
game it's just basically people do it
with no pain it sounds to me like you're
you're it's quaint that you're calling
it a game yeah drinking alcohol and
hitting each other is just something
people yeah we always we always called
that Saturday night yeah yeah as you
said slapping game and how hard do you
how hard do you slap I'm wearing makeup
down this side of my face because James
hit me pretty hard yesterday and I was
bruised this morning really yeah I wish
we had more time this has been
absolutely fantastic and if we did have
more time I'd let you slap me but we're
out of time oh you can do it go all
right
that was the best and worst thing that
ever happened to me we are thrilled that
you could be here thank you so much for
coming here from making so many people
so happy the stars of
[Applause]